[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
on va beaucoup parler de jardin et d'un
jardin extraordinaire qui se trouvent
dans les yvelines et qui s'appelle le
bois du fait et aimer pourparlers alors
rhodia jean charles lajoie ni bonjour
bonjour
cet éditeur vous avez délire et publier
un livre sur une plante s'appelle une
plante s'appelle mitroshina mithra gina
très inquiète une plante aux vertus très
prometteuse alors dans les sénégalais se
servent beaucoup en médecine
traditionnelle et qui intéresse ce
beaucoup on peut dire d'un côté hélas
dans le roman en tout cas mais dans la
vie tant mieux et ça intéresse beaucoup
les labos pharmaceutiques pour toutes
les propriétés assez prometteuse que les
espère pouvoir tirer de cette lente
notamment pour la lutte contre le
paludisme ont fait la curieuse maladie à
jaden vézina bonjour à patrice vous êtes
enseignante de vous être maître de
conférences de de droit à rouen et à
sciences po
voilà jean baptiste du club vous êtes à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
et puis je suis ravi d'accueillir césar
garçons bonjour pas comment ça va très
bien très bien pas l'air d'être là c'est
grâce à vous qu'on va parler de jardin
on va pas les deux choses grâce à vous
de jardin puisque vous êtes photographe
vous a fait vous avez publié récemment
fut récemment un livre sur les plus
beaux jardins d'italie vraiment un
premier livre que vous aviez publié
s'appelle le bois du fait c'est surtout
un grand jardin quito min dans les
yvelines et puis on va parler aussi de
votre grand père qui était un grand
avocat qui était maurice garçon et dont
le journal est paru le 1er tome 2
journal tic qui vous pour par les années
de guerre 39 45 il y aura d'autres tomes
qui vont paraître on va pas vous parler
aussi
on va d'abord parler du jardin de ce
bois du fait
alors comment vous l'avez découvert
comme le dit voilà la chanson c'était
vraiment jardin extraordinaire qui est
dedans la culture et communes qui se
situe dans la commune de milly saint
denis qui s'appelle le bois du fait qui
est en fait un le nom d'un quartier 2010
de 5 10 et c'est un jardin qui a été
créée il ya une quarantaine d'années qui
donc à maturité aujourd'hui
panaméricains marc rodriguez qui a été
abandonnée aujourd'hui un très vieux
monsieur mais qui a été abordé dans les
années 80 sollicité par jack lang pour
réaliser le jardin la bande centrale du
jardin d'une étude de palais royal qui a
réalisé un très joli jardin aussi au
musée américain de paix en cours et qui
a surtout réalisé ce chef-d'oeuvre qui
est son propre jardin dans la vallée de
chevreuse voilà donc c'est un jardin qui
a été réalisée au milieu d'une forêt
dans un vallon profond en deux temps et
il a aménagé ce jardin comme il est
américain et de la partie s des états
unis du connecticut
il a vraiment réalisé jardin comme un
jardin américain avec des essences
d'arbres qui à l'automne fond on
parvient à véritablement à un été indien
il à dire tout d'un coup c'est là c'est
lent c'est la saison des intel voilà
c'est d'ailleurs là c'est en train de
tourner cette action extraordinaire est
en fait les feuillages change de couleur
quand les nuits sont très froides que
les journées sont très chauds c'est
exactement ce qui est en train de se
passer
voilà aussi des photos d'isa plein qui
sont vos photos qui sont donc dans ce
livre il s'appelle donc le le bois du
fait que vous avez publié aux éditions
ulmer qui le l'éditeur que deux radeaux
de livres sur les jardins mais comme
vous l'avez découvert vous et bien en
fait j'avais commandité marque redskins
pour faire pour réaliser mon jardin à
meudon j'habitais à l'époque dans les
hauts-de-seine et j'avais demandé à mark
de réaliser qu'ils étaient venus dîner
un jour ils n'avaient pas je vais pas
vraiment demandé il avait à la fin du
dîner j'habitais cette maison avec un
jardin potentiel et il m'avait envoyé
par fax un plan pour me remercier du
dîner et j'ai gardé le plan j'ai
respecté le plan qui m'avait envoyé et
suspendre des années des années j'ai
travaillé voilà j'ai travaillé à partir
de son plan et nous sommes devenus très
amis et quand
j'ai changé de métier j'avais une
entreprise une agence photo une
entreprise et que j'ai vendu donc je
suis devenu photographe de jardin
j'avais jamais touché un appareil vous
êtes venu à la photo par le jardin sinon
suis venu à la photo par jardin j'ai
toujours été passionné par l'art ti
culture la botanique et donc j'ai suivi
des cours à l'année nikon school comme
la marque de l'appareil qui ce qui est
une école formidable et pendant un mois
pour apprendre à manipuler un appareil
de photo je n'avais jamais fait une
photo de ma vie et donc j'en ai parlé un
soir à ce merveilleux monsieur marc
quinn qui me dit avec son accent
américain je te confie mon jardin
pendant un an à la main et j'ai suivi
des quatre-saisons merveilleux une année
merveilleuse
voilà un automne flamboyant un printemps
plein d'eau et de soleil et de vapeur 1
et exquis tout était beau et la neige en
février donc j'ai tout eu toi tu es tu
es je plante m
mon trépied au même endroit enfin
j'essayais je me prête je mettais des
vous savez les petits pics pour le golf
là pour proposer sa balle et les ti
jeunes étaient des teams évidemment ça
disparaît c'est à l'endroit où j'avais
mis bout à bout leurs adversaires
savaient mais j'arrivais à faire à peu
près les mêmes les mêmes vues comme ça
que ce soit au printemps où est allé à
l'hiver voilà donc on a ça donc c'est
vrai appris sur le tas si je puis dire
l'information fait la main tout seul
voilà absolument avec non avec quand
même en ayant beaucoup observé sur et
des photographes et la photo j'ai
visionné ce que c'était aussi un peu
votre d'avant et et comment ça s'est
passé
les éditions humaines ont été intéressés
par ces moutons alors là c'est génial
entraîneur bert qui est le patron du
maire je ne sais absolument pas je fais
les photos pendant un angle et puis midi
faut quand même je montre ça à quelqu'un
il faut que j'ai un peu un avis de
quelques années et j'avais toujours en
poche à dans cette collection des
jardins d'exception un des très très
beau livre que le maire avait publié qui
me semblait vraiment le modèle qu'il
fallait suivre et anthony lambert c'est
vraiment il m'a vraiment mis la main à
la
à la base le pied à l'étrier parce que
j'ai mal je vais montrer des photos et
quarante cinq minutes après mais dit
monsieur on va publier
voilà comment ça a démarré et alors ce
jardin aujourd'hui puisque ma retraite
qui comme vous le dites les vieux
monsieur aujourd'hui assez qui peut plus
s'en occuper personnellement donc alors
il
il a une équipe qui est formidable
depuis que j'en à persiste que cela
existe toujours mais marc röthlin est
aujourd'hui un très vieux monsieur âgé
est toute la question américain donc
avec de la famille qui vit aux états
unis au début d'année et qui il a deux
neveux qui sont formidables parce qu'ils
sont très respectueux de l'oeuvre de
mark rutte qui n'est ils sont très
soucieux de la pérennité de ce jardin ça
va devenir et aujourd'hui voilà la
question se pose qu'est-ce que ça va
devenir de ce que ça va devenir mais il
de 2 ha 50 autres mais c'est quand même
plus le ferai parce que c'est un
entretien de milliards de fois par an
parce que c'est du nettoyage à terme
c'est c'est au minimum de 2000 à 3000
euros par mois de frais donc c'est ce
qui serait idéal nerveuse et s'éteint
dans un endroit merveilleux qui est
inconstructible donc hautement protégé
dans la vallée de chevreuse
ce qui serait idéal et merveilleux
évidemment c'est que le ou ses neveux ou
des gens passionnés de jardins puisse
reprendre cette propriété parce qu'ils
n'existent pas en france d'organiser
comme en angleterre qui s'appelle
nahshon trust et qui permet à des
familles qui n'ont par exemple dans le
cadre sans descendance mais avec une
propriété importante de pouvoir laisser
avec une somme d'argent bien entendu
pour gérer l'entreprise la propriété de
laisser à un organisme national une
propriété en france ça n'existe pas et
il ya beaucoup de gens la rochefoucauld
objet de la rochefoucauld qui est un
très très beau jardin des bruyères c'est
beau coupé siea s'est beaucoup occupé de
ça pour essayer de développer cet
organisme national qui consistera qui
pourrait récupérer des du patrimoine de
architectural ou robots ou un petit col
mais ça n'existe pas pour l'instant
et d'ailleurs dont il ya des risques
d'abandon comme risque d'abandon et un
jardin d'intérieur ciment oui oui c'est
celle ci n'est pas entre deux séances en
une saison c'est fini tout pareil tu
pars avant tout tout tout ce que toutes
les tailles ce ne sont pas fait tout
part à vau l'eau le lait l'herbe montée
gens qui les gens qui dans l'herbe ne
disparaissent ils s'étaient tous fait
état et une réflexion intéressante si si
les yvelines était en angleterre il y
aurait 400 ou 300 jardins privés
passionnant ouvert au public dans les
yvelines
et si versailles était un angle de
taille de ré 40 ou 30 jardin urbain
passionnant à visiter il existe et il a
priorisé la société d'édition de ses
soldats à bahreïn il ya le parc
et puis si elles veulent potager
merveille mais il n'y a pas de l'art des
jardins privés des neuneus n'existe pas
ici il ya des gens là privée des
citoyens c'est un blues alors qu'il faut
livrer ces anglais il aurait fait des
vides et des bordures détail d'état
pierre enfin il reste plein de choses et
se serait ouvert au public pendant les
deux jours de desjardins ouvertes le
jardin loi du fait là il est ouvert au
public ou sur demande sur dont voilà sur
demande faire en ce moment c'est
compliqué parce que comme cela je me
suis quand même très très très
voilà vieillissant maintenant il faut
plutôt pas trop le déranger maintenant
puis la saison se termine donc voilà
c'est un peu le la fin voilà peut-être
espérons qui a rien à nouveau un nouvel
espoir pour ce jardin à venir oui vous
êtes pas désespérée quand même l'avenir
ans
non non non mais mais c'est quand même
une vraie question sur la question qui
fu chi plus beaucoup plus général pour
plein de propriété pour plein de parc
pour plein de château oui c'est ça
qu'est ce que ça fait du bien parce que
là vous avez raison c'est très cher
d'entretien oui oui oui les héritiers
ont pas fait celui de la chasse ouverte
et les héritiers comme les gens meurent
de plus en plus âgés les héritiers
n'attendent pas de deux d'hériter de la
propriété familiale pour acheter une
propriété est allé passer des millièmes
train donc eux-mêmes à 60 ans ils ont
encore leurs parents mais ils vont
acheter eux mêmes une propriété donc à
son bras il se retrouve à la mort de
leurs parents avec une politique qui est
en plus d'en être souvent dans les dix
vit donc ils vont ils vous ont plutôt
tendance à la vendre voilà donc c'est ça
le c'est tout un système d'ailleurs je
crois que berne stéphane bern très
consciente tout ça il ya une émission
sur le plus beau jardin france oui oui
oui voilà et puis cette histoire du
patrimoine
oui c'est un patrimoine qui risque de
disparaître
vous êtes sensible aux on est sensible
aussi à entendre que malheureusement ils
peuvent mourir par
défaut d'entretien par abandon et c'est
vrai que cette inexistence d'une
autorité publique ou même d'une forme d'
aide qui pourrait être apportée à
l'entretien de ces jardins je la trouve
désolante pour notre patrimoine pour
notre culture aussi parce que le jardin
alors je ne suis pas sûr qu'on puisse
parler de jardin à la française pour
pour celui ci mais ça fait quand même
milliken d'accord rapidement perdre on
n'a jamais terminé avant non mais
j'avais juste pression parce que jardin
à la française on voit à peu près jardin
anglaise on voit à peu près et les
ardennes américaine c'est quoi c'est le
mélange des beaucoup d'arbres beaucoup
d'arbres beaucoup d'américains soudé
adore les arbres et puis ça fait partie
intrinsèque de la nature comme les
écarts levée quand lés les premiers
européens sont arrivés en amérique les
richesses de la des essences d'arbres en
amérique dont beaucoup d'arbres 7 cette
espèce de magie du paysage reste
américain à l'automne vraiment
extraordinaire et donc on retrouve au
bas du fait ça c'est très amusant et
après un jardin plus formel en bakhit
qui est là comme un jardin plus
classique avec des buis taillés dé des
ifs taille et voilà et puis d'aider
quelques années et pour finir parce
qu'on voit pas mais quelques vivaces qui
sont typiquement américaine les asters
qui viennent qui viennent d'amérique
voilà donc il y en a beaucoup et il
était assez touchants de les retrouver
là dans la nature sauvage
voilà c'est quoi pour vous un beau
jardin vous avez des conditions ben non
j'ai pas de définition mais je trouve
qu'il ya tellement de beaux jardins en
france est absolument partout
tout à fait d'accord avec vous c'est
sûrement dommage car il y en a qui
disparaissent mais il y en a quand même
énormément à visiter on peut et on peut
même passer des journées des week-ends
entiers est baladé en france on trouve
des jardins absolument somptueux de même
plus petit que celui que vous évoquez
beaucoup moins deux hectares y en a qui
sont gigantesques il ya une profusion je
pense qu'un amour des français pour les
beaux jardins qui se développe sûrement
surtout peut-être grâce à vous grâce à
des beaux bouquins et c'est parce que
c'est magnifique et puis ce sans être un
peu bisounours mais un côté retour à la
nature de plus en plus besoin coin
jardin c'est apaisant c'était c'est
extrêmement agréable comme vous le dit
très justement on est dans une région
d'al enfin un pays où on a la chance
d'avoir quatre saisons bien marquer donc
cesser ces quatre jardins différence est
extraordinaire bon franchement et des
yvelines c'est pas pour ça c'est
magnifique
dans paris il ya des jardins superbe bon
à jardin albert kahn à qui promeut à
boulogne un maquis qui est en travaux
mais bon voilà ça va ça va se régler je
trouve qu'on a quand même un patrimoine
qu'il faut pas caricaturer la fin
beaucoup oui beaucoup
les journées des lésés ils payent de
conscience et de découverte
ça donne des idées aux gens qui ont de
grands espaces
il bat tiens pourquoi est ce que au lieu
d' effectivement au lieu d'une belle
pelouse effectivement peut-être de temps
en temps faire des choses et c'est donc
et c'est formidable par un propriétaire
et puis la crise donne beaucoup de mal
et que du coup il peut l'ouvrir à des
gens avaient à des visiteurs et il peut
expliquer expliquer ce qui la fait
partager c'est pas seulement dans le
dans le sens des visiteurs que kaki qui
découvre un jardin c'est très agréable
pour le propriétaire
oui parce que oui puisque pêché c'est
dans ton truc dans son coin c'est rare
les actions dont on voit immédiatement
le résultat 118,9 algérien et puis il ya
par exemple si un travail remarquable
qui fait souvent france sur le
recensement des arbres des arbres
remarquables etc
c'était vraiment bien géré les arts
vraiment intéressants sont identifiés on
peut aller les voir à certaines
occasions que c'est ferran qui sont des
arts tu mens sublime extrêmement vieux
ou d'une autre et anciens
des formes souvent insensé et tout ça
est plutôt bienvenu bien mis en valeur
j'ai été pas mal mais pas lui j'ai été
il ya quinze jours
j'étais invité très gentiment par alain
baraton qui m'a fait montrer les essais
de ce qui vient à prendre même avec les
1600 ils sont atteints de maladies ou de
pirater la virade donc et c'est un vrai
problème dans certaines propriétés
d'ailleurs versailles et à versailles en
question oui et donc il ya une fille
former des jeunes femmes formidables qui
nous est bonne
qui travaille avec marathon et qui est
chargé donc de ces essais pour remplacer
le puits qui est à moyen terme condamnés
a condamné donc donc il j'ai visité ça
c'était tout à fait intéressant parce
qu'ils ont fait des essais en plantant
dans des parterres à la suite des pluies
qui avaient qu'ils ont ôté différentes
variétés de 2,2 de feu nu pour remplacer
le lobby tout brûle brûle où tout est
atteint par la maladie il y en a un
vaguement qui n'est pas de chèvre fhd
noter la hadra qui pourrait peut-être
résisté et qui est le nanny me japonicus
c'est à dire une forme de fusée voilà
c'est peut-être celui ci qui pourrait
résister
c'est terrible c'est terrible donc les
apports des arbres des marronniers même
chose c'est bien dans le temps ce sont
des choses qui viennent de son tacticien
oui oui puisqu'il cite la police et le
transfert des plantes d'un continent à
l'autre d'un pays à l'autre à distance
mais on ne peut rien protégés de maddie
étrangères j'en passe moi je suis pas
spécialiste des jardins de la pêche
voilà donc repêché dans les jardins donc
forcément mais non j'essaye de comparer
ça avec ce que je connais est ce que je
fais en fait dire que moi comme juriste
il ya une maîtrise parfaite de mon objet
quand j'écris un article j'y mets mes
petits éléments mes arguments je fais un
plan de partis dessous parti je maîtrise
parfaitement mon objet quelque part
voilà alors que dans le jardin il ya une
volonté de maîtriser la nature de se
l'approprier d'une certaine manière et
puis en même temps il y aussi et c'est
là ce qui différencie un peu par rapport
à ce que je fais quelque chose qui nous
échappe parce qu'on peut pas non plus
complètement préjuger de la manière
les plantes vont évoluer des couleurs
des saisons des maladies
et donc je sais ça peut mourir et ça
peut ça peut vite d'une manière qui
n'est pas forcément prévisible et je
trouve que c'est aussi ça la magie d'un
jardin absolument
ce qui nous échappe à dire c'est ce qui
fait de plus le ce qui fait le charme
parce que en tailles hautes alpes et les
formes bien pris tous les couples et
puis tout d'un coup ça la magie qui est
dommage c'est qu'on ne l'a pas prévu
qu'ils arrivent et je voudrais qu'on
parle d'eux parce que peut-être que tout
le monde ne sait pas qui était maurice
garçon c'est votre grand père et c'était
un grand avocat académicien français et
dont le journal est publié aux éditions
des fire ça c'est le premier tome du
journal qui l'a 39 à 45
peut-être un mot sur hull d'abord sur
kiki était maurice garçon eh bien
c'était le fils du du pénaliste des 1000
garçons ils étaient c'est tout un
personnage très singulier il est né en
89 en 1889 et c'était impressionniste
est un acte un peintre amateur un
aquarelliste 1 1 2 2 il faisait du
cirque
enfin réédité à un écrivain il entré à
l'académie en 47 et et un grand arrêt
l'avocat
un des avocats du siècle avec les idées
fleuriot cédé 2 les deux figures figures
très très différents qui serait notre
île a été la gouaille parisienne avec
les curiosités parisien génial et
l'autre très haut très long
90 très hautain très très élégant et est
vraiment un autre esprit et puis un
avocat bervet yeux parce que c'était un
honnête homme oui la lettone donc le
journal le journal d'un honnête homme
c'est à dire un brave type à des gens
aux draps qui se retrouve 10e 34 p our
10930 cardiaque et c'est un grand
républicain piste est un donc et si
c'est une un constat de d'une chute
d'année en année du de son pays il on
met des valeurs de tout déballer rioux
alors il y là il est très lucide il est
très clairvoyant il a un truc et ce qui
est formidable parce que comme la
commune la la la la formation passer
très très peu à l'époque on ne sait rien
de ce qui se passe sur les fronts de
guerre on ne sait rien des intentions
des différents gouvernements parce que
parce que toute personne ne passe que
l'accueil l'information ne passait pas
et lui recoupent des choses comme ça il
essaye de comprendre et ils se trompent
pas beaucoup il comprend que il ya
certes un front qui sont vraiment des
brèches dans le le l'avancée allemande
il comprend pas mal beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de choses et puis il se rend
compte de 2 2 que toutes ces valeurs
le quai auquel qui lui tiennent à coeur
des vallées démocratie s'était pas
encore sous ces termes c'est un militant
militants c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que ce monde c'est un honnête
homme qui est pris dans cette attente et
que ce monde de la troisième république
dans lequel vivaient des rats que le
monde de l'après guerre de 14 est en
train de c'est un nouveau un autre monde
qui va à nouveau disparaître comme celui
d'avant guerre de 14 a disparu et est ce
en effet voilà c'est le jeune homme
entre paris sa propriété du poitou il
fait l'aller-retour tout le temps donc
il est à la fois comme il sort tout le
temps il a une vie mondaine importante
il voit la cour et la ville à paris et y
ait une demande importante est assurée
we know i'm été aussi plein après tout
les prévient de théâtre j'avais aussi
plaint donc il y va et cetera il
s'appelle il est très choqué par ce qui
se passe au moment où du pan de toit
jonah hill très belles pages sur contre
l'antisémitisme qu'il a écrite qui est
vraiment formidable
il y a un truc assez assez troublant
c'est que il existe un très beau au
journal qui est écrit par une jeune
fille juive délicieux journal mère dont
le prénom méchas
qui était la fille du patron du gym
kullmann donc c'était début de grand
bourgeois parisiens qui jouaient dans le
8e arrondissement et cette jeune fille
la guerre arrive juive la gare arrive au
moment où cette jeune fille passe le cap
de la puberté de 2,2 à celui d'une jeune
femme essaie son journal au milieu de ce
café accueille cataclysme de la guerre
et j'ai vraiment un journal très
touchant très très sensible et le jour
où elle publie de porter l'étoile jaune
le premier jour elles valent en
métropole à la sorbonne où elle suit des
cours et elle raconte dans son journal
que le talent jour le pourquoi le 12
l'envié elle a croisé dans le métro à
monsieur qui l'a regardé et que juste en
se regardant tous les deux ils ont
compris le drame qui se massaient dans
dans cette rame de métro de voir une
jeune fille portait une étoile jaune est
elle de la portée et le même jour mon
grand père écrit qu'il prend le métro
dans ce journal donc dans le même jour
qu'il croise le jour où le premier jour
on porte les dreads jaune qui croise une
jeune fille croit son regard et il dit
lui aussi et nous nous sommes compris
tout de suite
donc on pense les ducks et hélène berr
voilà et l'albert elle a croisé que
c'était que dans les deux journaux après
tu n'as que se croiser ces destins comme
ça voilà et donc le journal été publiées
grâce à enfin ça oui c'est désolant
c'était un truc intéressant c'est à dire
ben justement vous étiez dit
mon grand père avait n'a pas laissé n'a
pas fait publier livre son vivant il l'a
laissé en héritage à sa fille en lui
disant c'est toi qui décidera ce qu'il
est sexy je ne sais pas si ce livre a
une valeur quelconque et c'est à toi de
juger quelles responsabilités elle a été
formidable parce qu'elle a elle a mis du
temps il a fallu que oui ça aurait pu
incarner 40 ans avant qu'elle décide de
le publier
et heureusement qu'elle a fait parce que
ça fait c'est un succès fou une écriture
merveilleuse c'était un témoignage
formidable aux mineurs elle l'a fait
elle l'a fait elle a eu cette espèce de
coup de génie de considérer que c'était
une deux c'était une oeuvre très
intéressante
la preuve c'est que ça fait des ventes
ça fait drôle et il y aura un deuxième
temps malheur qui misera sur une époque
plus ancienne à césar non non c'est un
peu plus récente c'est le deuxième taux
s'est dit faisant 45 jusqu'à 147 parce
qu'on prépare je crois pour tourner et
donc c'est pascal froment qui s'en
occupe avec son complice dont le nom
m'échappe et et elle prépare ça c'est
passionnant parce que là c'est la
rentrée à l'académie française dont 47
avec tous les jeudis qui racontent tous
ses confrères il faut dire que
l'académie française en 47 il ya il ya
eu
deux ans écarté des cartes et donc les
doutes qui sont arrivés voilà et devenir
daubresse garçons les séances de
l'académie très amusant tout problème de
la guerre d'algérie moi je salue moi je
ne dis pas non non je le dis qu'au fur
et à mesure de la parce que c'est ma
tante en avait l'exclusivité pourrait
s'affaisser sont bien prend soin là et
est donc l'algérie puisque en fait il ya
toute cette période magique et
passionnante où les grands procès
d'après guerre évidemment
parce qu'elle est tous les grands procès
que d'autres donc d'occuper aussi pour
la double affaire devenait hardy c'est
après la guerre rené il a des défenseurs
de rené attendait de fin de vie il a
qu'il devait donner en bonne voie la
pelouse avec deux français très
compliqué l'histoire voilà donc et on
parle de lui aussi dans un livre qui a
acquis beaucoup de ce qui s'appelle la
serpe de philippe les doigts puisque
c'était lui qui avait défendu
arnaud enfin georges arnaud daguin du
salaire de la peur il était accusé
d'avoir tué sa femme en trois sets
voilà donc sur les avocats ou doivent
être un mot pour dire que c'est vrai que
nous en tant que maître de conférences
on a l'habitude de former des juristes y
passer des examens aux avocats oui bien
sûr c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment
qu'aujourd'hui alors on a parlé des
jardins à la française et des jardins
l'américaine peut-être qu'on pourrait
parler des avocats à la française et des
avocats à l'américaine on a le sentiment
que tous nos jeunes on se perd et que
les eaux peu dans sa s'américanise un
petit peu on devrait dans le dans le
dans la conception qu'ont les jeunes
juristes et on a peut-être envie de leur
conseiller la lecture du journal de
maurice garçon pour leur dire qu'il ya
du livret a qui perdent d'un avocat
voilà à l'éloquence oui à mon sens bien
sûr et le goût d'écrire aussi le lyrisme
l'engagement le sens de l'autre
finalement dit marek richard berry afin
twin abusif et respecte sur 5,5
plaidoirie ac c'est formidable donc
voilà il ya
la faire un outil il ya une très belle
plaidoirie sur véronique courjault
encourt la peine de mort y est belle
parce que au fond on peut pas nier que
cette femme
ces nouveaux nés et l'avocat termine en
lui disant b
reconnaissez-vous déshabituer
reconnaissez que vous devez tuer et me
consacrer vous maintenant aux autres
enfants et à votre mari ça c'est beau
parce qu'il ne peut pas j'aimerais qu'il
peut pas nier et enfin il peut pas
défendre la non culpabilité quoi et on
ressort qu'en moyenne il ya
dupond-moretti aussi qu'il va prendre la
parole va bientôt à du beau marais
d'yves c'est pas le premier parce que
jacques vergès fait aussi un spectacle
est là on va publier à au printemps
prochain quatre grands plaidoirie
garçons la sphère greenspan alors ça
c'est quand même un morceau parce que je
ne sais pas tu sais celui qui avait
assassiné sept ce diplomate allemand ce
juif polonaise qui avait assassiné ce
diplomate allemand 38 à paris et après
l'assassinât de ce diplomate allemand
survient évidemment la nuit cristal la
soi-disant vengeance du peuple est
également organisée par le régime
paritaire les piqueuse d'orsay qui est
une affaire invraisemblable où les les
des médecins de l'hôpital d'orsay
pendant le
pendant le moment s'appelle le moment où
tous deux rames delà de la débâcle
vous avez tous tous les médecins sont
partis en laissant en place et oui avec
des vieux et elle serait plus comme les
mairies les ventes nettes grimpent donc
elles ont pris la décision donc il ya eu
un procès retentissant en 42 alors en
pleine guerre aaw grand-père a défendu
sa famille elle était livrée à elle même
sans responsable là il dit mais c'est la
faute des médecins il a dit c'est la
faute des médecins et d'y inscrire vos
meilleurs costumes par lydia truc
formidable que j'ai apportée pour vous
et que j'ai pas apporté finale grave
c'était un extrait de la plaidoirie mais
je les passais pas grave mais et puis
ils vont publier l'assassinât du la
plaidoirie pour la salle et le procès
des étudiants de poitiers qui avait
assassiné un collaborateur
et puis la double affaire rené hardy qui
va faire revenir aux affaires
c'est mon rêve je les avais jamais on va
filer le bouquin à richard berry pour
qu'il termine aussi par par ces ouvrages
qui a publié robert badinter aussi
qu'ils comprennent alors pas
nécessairement ses plaidoiries mais en
tout cas tout ça je trouve aussi toute
sa vie d'homme à travers les grandes
affaires qu'il a eu à juger notamment
son combat pour l'abolition donc yaya ou
s'il ya de la très belle littérature sur
la question alors il était un peu dans
l'autre cirque avec maurice garçon et
via charles aznavour d'hommage national
c'est vrai c'est vrai que non mais c'est
théo est ce que c'était pas oui quelques
années c'était surtout de la vème
république pas que de la cinquième
non c'est avant tout son âge oui mais
c'est ce qui est effectivement très
curieux c'est que il est tout à fait
reconnu et connu et apprécié par toutes
les générations même les mêmes raisons
très jeune
oui absolument chanteur à la reprise et
ce en soi même et même le
les gens qui ont 18 18 19 que dans ce
sens ils connaissent très bien cet amour
c était en cours causé sa mort est tombé
enfin l'annoncé de sa mort est tombé et
des étudiants qu'entre 18 et 19 ans qui
ont persuadé que sur les 30 élèves et 28
qui connaissait très bien nous
débrouiller mais si on connaît est
capable de citer des chansons d'aznavour
absolument ce coach et moi j'étais
persuadé que j'allais me dirai donc on
connaît pas qui est qui et qui est ce
type externe dans le tome c'est assez
exceptionnel
une histoire d'intégration si la
désintégration presque vous élire de
simulation passé voilà quelqu'un qui
arrive offrant ses parents ne parlent
pas un mot de français ils ont peint ou
un état et il va être au four pendant
toute sa vie le défenseur de d'une
certaine langue française et même les
images ou alors ses plus belles chansons
reste encore une des années 60 70
il avait l'impression de dire mieux
aujourd'hui qui n'écrivait cette époque
là c'était assez bout et quand vous
parler d'intégration il faut parler
aussi de cette double culture justement
parce que c'est à la fois aujourd'hui
l'un des monuments de notre patrimoine
français avec nos jardins on pourrait
mais des chansons de charles aznavour en
regardant le merveilleux ouvrage
ailleurs mais c'est l'arménie aussi et
qui il a fait beaucoup pour son pays a
été représentant pour l'onu il a été
ambassadeur auprès de la suisse etc pour
parler de ce qu'on vient finalement il
disait souvent qu'il avait le sentiment
que sa réussite était aussi un petit peu
nécessaire pour son peuple et qu'il
avait le sentiment d'apporter un petit
peu quelque chose à la légèreté dans mon
peuple arménien
besoin dans ces époques là donc il ya à
la fois je trouve la démonstration d'un
combat finalement politique mais très
serein très pacifique
on n'a pas les rappeurs d'aujourd'hui
qui se sent poindre dans des aéroports
on a quelqu'un qui se bat mais avec
beaucoup de lyrisme finalement et de et
de petits extras au respect de la langue
le respect de la langue mais surtout le
la passion possible pour deux nations
sans que ce soit l'une contre l'autre
carte et c'est ça ce serait idéal si
tout le monde pouvait prendre des leçons
de danse n'avoir qu' il adorait la
france il a voulu se faire enterrer en
france et la torture ça n'a jamais
empêché d'adorer l'arménie et d'être
quasiment arménien donc il n'a jamais
joué l'un contre l'autre je suis
français j'adore l'arménie que si
c'était une leçon que tout le monde
pouvait entendre ce serait même
bénéfique et que ce n'est pas forcément
un choix contre loire saison d'une
entité mère meurtrière quand il ya
justement celle de l appartenance et lui
c'est un conflit qui n'a pas en tout cas
penser comme tel c'est quelque chose il
a réussi à faire 700 d'ailleurs faire
une conciliation parce que souvent on
dit que c'est un mélange mais je crois
pas que c'est quelque chose qu'il a
surmontée si conflit il ya de cette
manière c'est à dire que pour lui il y
avait son amour pour la france ont un
mot pour l'arménie
c'était deux choses alors qu'ils
n'étaient pas complètement étanche mais
c'était deux passions différentes qu'il
vivait de manière différente et je
trouve ça formidable en tout cas dans la
manière dont il l'a vécue su faire un
parallèle imploser c'est un peu ce que
fait manuel valls aussi et oui donc
c'est le tout à fait je ne renie
relation est ce que j'adore j'adore
l'espace je suis né espagnol devenu
français
il a présenté à barcelone
bon très bien fait j'étais homo je lui
souhaite d'être élu il a eu d'abord le
courage d'être anti indépendantistes dès
le début c'était quand même assez
courageux à l'heure où tout le monde en
france est bien évidemment se sont rués
sur le truc assez merveilleux
ils manifestent donc ils ont raison ils
sont nombreux dont ils ont raison d'en
que la manuelle va ça vient comme andy
droit dans ses bottes événements ils ont
tort c'est une stupidité est sûre ça
assez courageux donc je lui souhaite le
plus grand succès peut-être que je vais
apporter un bémol j'ai l'intention oui
en plus j'ai un tout petit peu de peine
pour notre parlement français pas tant
pour son départ mais pour les - où il
l'a laissé complètement en déshérence
parce qu'il faut savoir que il a quand
même été rémunéré sur les fonds publics
et on a fait beaucoup de scandales avec
justement nos députés qui étaient
complètement absents et je crois que
pour son combat espagnole il ya un peu
abandonné le parlement français
voilà alors il et il était temps que
cette situation se clarifie je crois
qu'il a bien fait les choses aujourd'hui
en décidant justement de se consacrer
pleinement à sa vocation
mais peut-être qu'il ya eu quand même
une période de flou et où on aurait pu
attendre qu'il se consacre pleinement à
la fonction qui était la sienne en tant
que député ou qu'ils choisissent
peut-être plutôt de dire que cette
vocation nationale n'avait n'avait plus
de sens pour lui mais attention à
l'absence vous révolter contre
l'attitude des députés la france
insoumise qui dans l'hémicycle
brandissaient des panneaux bon débarras
c'est plus la santé ils confondent
assemblée écrié du marché enfin c'est
effectivement ça faisait siffler mais
c'est vrai que si on essaie de se placer
dans dans l'esprit de ses électeurs
enfin c'est quand même un contrat qui
est formée entre l'élu et et les
électeurs et de ce point de vue là c'est
vrai que le fait qu'il parte peut être
considéré comme un abandon à partir du
moment où il ne combat pas pour raisons
personnelles ou pour mettre fin à une
carrière mais pour prolonger un combat
politique et c'est vrai que
je pense qu'il peut on peut se sentir
abandonnés voyez c'est comme un un
contrat de mariage et un homme qui part
pour une autre femme si un homme meurt
c'est une chose différente pour moi je
suis en même temps enfin tout ça c'est
là aussi un changement je pense de vie
privée aussi fauqué qui est donc oui et
un mot plus général si on fait le
parallèle avec la sphère colons la
férule eau etc
on a le sentiment que pendant le temps
notamment celui qui avait publié les
mémoires du général de gaulle parlait
cette intoxication cavell et les
politiques au pouvoir comme comme si on
ne pouvait pas le quitter vraiment on
est dans la vague des politiciens qui
sont vont en tout cas qui nous démontre
que on peut se lasser d'un mandat avoir
envie d'autre chose et que finalement ça
n'est pas le combat de toute une vie on
ne meurt plus au pouvoir comme l'a fait
georges pompidou est bon là c'est
peut-être un changement d'époque
montfort sont invités ont ceci près que
lou qui sont glissés le politique parce
que cette colombe qui peut l'être
politique mais j'espère qu'il fera sa
politique oui et des sports il est pour
des raisons mais tous les deux de la vie
de deux civils
la ministre des sports enfin je n'ai pas
dans le secret des dieux m'enfin c'est
pas c'est que si alex qui voilà qui
explique plus sûrement qu'un désamour de
l'homme et ses flics jusqu'à présent il
y avait très peu de désordre iv jacques
douffiagues s'est passé le nom vous dit
quelque chose qui a été une liste qui a
arrêté la politique du jour au lendemain
et eu quelques heures mais c'est très
rare
généralement c'est vrai mais puisqu'il
était imaginé quand il passe de premier
ministre à députés alors c'est une
espèce de majorité un peu flottante dans
dans la cale certains l'aiment d'autres
le détestent pense qu'il était aussi un
peu je pense que les paires d'yeux de ce
jeu fait aulas et qu'il est parti et
probablement pas pour lui sur la place
mais parce qu'il avait envie d'autre
chose
non mais c'est vrai qu'il avait pas la
place qu'il aurait pu pour ses mérites
et au sein de la majorité qu'il avait
rejoint kiel et c'était assez courageux
de sa part ce probable de mener en plein
de manuel valls à mais c'est vrai que
mais d'une certaine façon emmanuel
macron quand tu es d et es lui avait un
peu théorisé cette idée que le temps des
politiciens qui restait attaché à la vie
politique toute leur vie était été
déplacées du coup c'est vrai quand vous
êtes président à 39 ans il sera sûrement
à 49 ou pire oui c'est un nom mais je
veux dire vous pouvez penser faire autre
chose à sa traitant ces deux-là
politiquement revenir aznavour que vous
avez parlé de mon idée tu as simplement
a peut être disparu pas son étoile pas
son étoile un poète et un peu tweet
c'est ça très amoureux de la langue
un amour de la langue française par un
petit peu delà du débat sur la pma
procréation médicale assistée donc qui
est autorisé fall le conseil d'éthique
n'autorise pour les femmes seules ou
les femmes en couple et ça fait un débat
qui ressemble un peu à celui qu'on a eu
au moment du mariage pour tous en un
raidissement de la société l'église
l'évêque de paris a fait une interview
dans le parisien je crois en disant 10
en appelant les fidèles tous les fidèles
à se mobiliser contre cette ouverture de
la paix m alors on peut parler de lui du
fond des choses mais est ce que vous
sentez peut-être une sorte de
raidissement de la société un géo
revient à des valeurs un peu ancienne
est ce que c'est ça la france parce que
c'est le retour à la france et ça de
retour à des valeurs anciennes ou pas je
sais pas mais ce que je trouve assez
curieux c'est que ça me paraît pas être
la préoccupation principale des français
à l'heure actuelle la pma ça concerne
quoi s'est jamais maintenant que
maintenant ce sont des thèmes qui
concernent à mon avis moins de 1% de la
population et dont on voudrait faire
croire que 99% la population aurait un
avis et ce serait extrêmement tranché
c'est des choses qui ne qui concerne
elle avait 6 % de la population pourquoi
se mobiliser autant qu'au printemps mais
est un qui se mobilisent pour l'instant
aller dans les campagnes les gens se
mobilisent pas pour la pma le dénigre
autre magnifique après ça devienne un
combat politique récupérés par les uns
par les autres c'est autre chose
mais le problème de base et après bon
sur le fond du truc
ce qui était intéressant dans le
l'interview de lavey que dont le nom
m'échappe mais reid le nouveau le
veulent ce qu'ils disent et c'est quand
même institut institutionnaliser le fait
qu'on puisse se passer d'un père donc
voilà ça c'est juste un élément
intéressant et qui prête une véritable
discussion
après on peut tout on peut être content
mais en tout cas ça fait ça me paraît
assez juste mais justement je pense que
finalement la crispation du débat telle
qu'elle existe elle prouve bien qu'on ne
se concentre pas sur le fond des choses
la famille l'existence du d'un droit à
la vie toutes ces questions là peut-être
même des questions juridiques passe en
second plan par rapport à une forme
d'attachement à ce qu'ils étaient avant
par exemple si on prend la loi sur
l'abolition de la peine de mort je crois
qu'un sondage qu'avait dû être pris de
deux jours avant le vote de la loi ne
vous montrez que vous ferez 85% des
français et est hostile à cette
évolution
je pense que si on prenait la loi sur
l'usagé ç'aurait été exactement la même
chose qu'on appelle l'effet de sociétés
en france ont tendance à la location
tout à fait d'accord
allawi sur l'abolition avant tout à fait
un sondage 3 qui avait été fait par le
figaro qui avait en tout cas eu un une
ampleur nationale donc sa peine de mort
ça va alors aujourd'hui on en fait bah
oui on mi temps mais absolue exacte
absolue vis terroir et gm dit je me
présente à la présidence de la
république cette pression bien tenté je
sache que une majorité de français est
pour la peine de mort je dis que moi si
tu es du jabot lirez cette peine de mort
et a fait et ça a été alors bref c'est
très intéressant parce que les
spécialistes de sources politiques on va
je peux pas votre contrôle mais disent
que cela peut-être apporter plus de vote
de man a enlevé parce qu'il y avait le
courage d'affronter l'opinion aussi tout
à fait un courage politique et puis un
courage aussi d'aller peut-être à
l'encontre d'anders va-t-il qui
finalement
un peu la population française au moment
de tous les changements et moi j'ai le
sentiment que par contre je ne suis pas
d'accord avec le fait que les gens s'en
fichent un peu à mon sens finalement on
réveille un instinct primaire de voilà
de révolte contre le changement des
choses qui me semblent plus plus plus
générale que particulier plus le goût de
la polémique
en fait une sorte de crispation profonde
mais le sentiment je pense même
généralisée que on est face à un sujet
qui tôt ou tard arrivera nécessairement
on n'est pas je pense dans quelque chose
on se dira voilà ça sera fixé à 500g
coup là que j'ai appris mais j'ai là
vous l'avez gaspard le gaspard koenig et
il vient mot mickey et me semble évident
mais quelle que soit l'idée est qu'on a
sur les super mais c'est c'est
irrésistible
comment voulez vous qu'on puisse avec la
technique la technologie maintenant
aujourd'hui permet cette avancée
fantastique de pouvoir faire des enfants
pour des gens qui pour une raison x y z
ne pouvais pas en faire pour lesquels
c'est un désir profond et une écoute
doivent le faire mais comment est-ce
qu'on peut résister à ça c'est pas
possible et levier et comment peut-on
dire à ces gens vous ne pouvez pas dit
n'avait le droit ni ne pourrait jamais
d'en faire d'une injustice absolue sur
tous les plans d'eau il dit se moquer je
trouve très juste c'est sereinement les
manière irrésistible et ça veut dire
alors si on va plus loin que ça ça veut
dire que si c'est irrésistible alors il
ya deux solutions soit on l'interdît
s'est offert le dos soit on organise
exactement est-ce que c'est pas mieux de
réaliser des choses que de tourner le
dos à quelque chose qui est puissant et
irrésistible la lega la légalisation
permettrait de démocratiser de réguler
et d'encadrer une pratique aujourd'hui
réservé aux plus aisés le plus
débrouillard en s'assurant du
consentement éclairé des parties et en
permettant la reconnaissance officielle
dans l'état civil des enfants des de la
gp11 la cgpme voilà mes combat est fini
on va réagir
et le débat suivant c'est celui-là on va
y venir en dépit de toutes les promesses
comme d'habitude je ne parle pas de la
politique c'est un débat qui va
traverser la société par le petit en bas
âge je dis pas que je dis pas que man on
man a fait l'un des passagers père j'en
sais rien du tout de mâcon mais ce que
j'ai fait qu'effectivement il vous
semblez le dire tous les deux vous c'est
irrésistible utile et on va y venir
c'est à dire que on a dit aussi n'est
pas vraiment des ruses et le pacs et le
pacs les premiers opposants au pacs andy
bell non parce que eux le pacs après
c'est le premier pas vers le mariage
pour tous et au moment du pacs souvenez
vous cédez jamais jamais jamais de la
vie rassurez-vous le pacs et le pacs
donne évidemment cinq ans après yann
mariage pour tous les âges pour tous les
gens qui étaient contre
ah ben non parce que les mariages pour
tous on va avoir le mérite mais jamais
de la vie mais vous plaisantez j'espère
que vous les connaissez
mais à chaque fois on prend quand même
les gens pour des cons et ça c'est quand
même extrêmement gênant alors disons le
clairement comme vous leviez sous une
route qui vont découvrir s'il part des
fai des étapes les maladies et ses
suppositions déteste qu'on va tout
admettre d'envoyer ce tassement un grand
manitou derrière tout ce nom me disant
si vous pensez qu effectivement un peu
la théorie du complot ça du tout parce
que si c'était saint brès instable ça
prend vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
discussions beaucoup de réflexion et
c'est tout à fait passionnant quand il
ya des geôliers des lladounes du
militantisme contre qui tu te fais à mon
avis tout à fait pays natal intéressant
mais ça prend beaucoup beaucoup de quand
même de réflexion passionnante surtout
l'avenir de l'humanité sur l'avenir de
la famille sur elle et du tout que ça
n'est pas prendre les gens pour des cons
parce que franchement nous allons
d'étape en étape c'est vrai que c'est un
peu téléphoné et ses terres que c'est
évident que l'étape suivant décidée par
l'état parce que parce que c'est
irrésistible et parce que la réflexion
se fait la sélection parce qu'on y
réfléchisse à provoque une réflexion
quand même et c'est là justement le truc
la chose intéressante c'est que nous
justement nous sommes nous ne sommes pas
dans une période d'obscurantisme ni nous
évoluons nous évoluons très vite et je
trouve que l'époque est formidable pour
ça parce que justement nous sommes
portés vers toutes ces évolutions sans
obscurantisme sens
voilà avec ce n'est pas une forme ce
n'est pas la tolérance n'est pas le bon
mot mais il n'y a pas de l'obscurantisme
dans notre société des charges sont
formidables voilà voilà
et vous aviez aussi parce que les parcs
va vite y ait une sociologue et à linky
pas tout à fait d'accord avec vous qu'il
dit justement qui avec un auteur de
retour de l'obscurantisme rampant en
france qu' il ya 10 15 ans 20 ans on
admettez que les gens puissent vivre
leur vie comme il voulait voilà avec
avec les avec l'ailé avec les valeurs
qu'ils avaient et qu'aujourd'hui on a il
ya peut-être un peu un dans une certaine
partie de la société en tout cas un
petit retour en arrière vers une
certaine obscurité exactement vers
l'interdiction ouvert vers le retour à
des valeurs passées et c'est sur des
crispations et les crispations
ça me rappelle un peu le débat qu'on
avait pu avoir sur l'intelligence
artificielle mans où justement
finalement toute évolution technologique
irrésistible fait peur parce que
finalement sa rivale en ou l'angoissé de
l'avenir
le fait de ne pas pouvoir forcément
maîtriser ce que sera demain mais quand
tu disais comprenez on parlait pas
forcément suffisamment pédagogiquement
des choses je pense que si on nous avait
annoncé il ya vingt ans que notre iphone
vous reconnaîtrez par notre visage
on aurait sauté au plafond et finalement
il ya toute cette évolution qui se fait
aussi par le temps par les moeurs par
une forme de mondialisation aussi des
phénomènes ça vient souvent des états
unis et on se rend compte que ce qui
nous apparaissait révolutionnaire il ya
quelques années apparaît finalement tout
à fait classique aujourd'hui donc
peut-être que c'est l'évolution et le
progrès que c'est l'évolution des moeurs
et du temps qui nous permet de nous
faire à l'idée aussi il ya un autre à
l'époque le scellier en disant voilà
c'est aujourd'hui réservé peut-être plus
ri c'est que on est dans une société
mondialisée donc c'est s'est permis dans
certains pays on s'en reparle de par
exemple la gpa elle est autorisée dans
certains pays elles étaient bien comment
ça se passe ce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
recours en allant voilà dans des pays où
ces permis aux nazis justement
vous disiez que là ça dénote d'une
certaine angoisse de l'avenir
si vous prenez les gens individuellement
qui eux font des pma et et intérêts ils
sont pas du tout angoissé par l'avenir
il fonce parce que tout d'un coup ils
ont eu aucune possibilité formidable de
venteuse pour leur avenir pour l'avenir
de leur famille etc
ils ont aucune angoisse de l'avenir ce
sont deux vagues opinion qui ont de
capital si vous aviez mais les gens faut
prendre garde les gens individuellement
ce qu'ils font des pma et qui se lance
dans ce projet là et c'est peut-être
c'est comme c'est une aventure
individuelle quand même donc il faut
aussi respecter ça s'est passé
ils n'ont pas peur de l'avenir dr yvon
tout et je suis d'accord avec vous
manque d'expérience concrète de gens qui
peuvent nous dire que ça n'est pas on
peut dédiaboliser aussi ce type de débat
c'est pareil aussi avec tous les débats
de société je pense à l'euthanasie je
pense arriver j'ai finalement avant de
réglementer on a des pratiques
obscurantistes dangereuse pour la santé
des gens et aujourd'hui on pourrait tout
à fait régulier quelque chose de deux
seins finalement qu'ils ne changeraient
pas tellement la face du monde je suis
d'accord avec vous on accord peut-être
trop d'importance à ce qu'on craint oui
pas forcément oui oui oui voilà tout ce
temps passe suisse passe même parce que
en fait peu de gens viennent témoigner a
dit marc olivier fogiel il sort un livre
actuellement qu'il ya deux filles qui
l'est pas alors ce sont des figures
aussi qu'il est assez courageux meilleur
parce que après tout les gens pourraient
rester n'est pas obligé d'étaler la
bourse avait primé mais je pense qu'il a
il a sorti que fallait c'était le moment
de s'expliquer avec les doutes qu'on
peut avoir d'ailleurs s'est passé pas si
c'est pas univoque et voilà et puis
c'est le rôle des figures aussi
peut-être de roulement la socialement
ça existe déjà c'est la génération 3g ça
marche et moi d'ailleurs je crois que le
basculement vers la pma c'est une sorte
de retour à la tradition
c'en est volontairement provocateur mais
il faut quand même rappeler que le
mariage il a été pensé dans notre code
civil comme une institution permettant
la procréation par les jeunes la famille
et la survie de la semaine ce boulot
lorsqu'on est passé au mariage pour tous
c'était un argument qui était avancée
pour dire mais il faut pas rêver on
prévoit recevoir était justement on ne
permet pas de constituer une vraie né
quelque part la pma elle permet de
casser ça et de revenir finalement aux
institutions à la tradition permettant
justement aux couples homosexuels de
permettre de leur permettre d'avoir des
enfants justement est de constituer avec
du coup ça devient un vrai mariage c'est
en fait vous avez confiance dans la
surcharge
ça ne va pas du tout faux que vous
revenir à des valeurs traditionnelles
abasourdi parce que j'aime parce que
vous vous tenez comme discours tous les
quatre ans avant tout en disant de toute
façon ça va arriver acceptons tous je
dis pas qu'il faut pas m'aimer audio
bose ça arrive alors toute façon bas
légiférons et puis on attend la
prochaine innovation en dira si cette
sorte de deux fois absolument l'avenir
en disant que tout ce qui va arriver et
bien ce jeu me laisse perplexe
enfin petit pour être sacré
ces nouveaux noms mais ce afin d'offrir
et allons-y on se précipite et ont couru
la veille à 4 a toujours cherché à
assurer un peu de votre avis aussi mais
il se trouve quand même parce que tout
d'un coup on est dans un cadre social
qui est super blindé sur le plan
démocratique quand même donc nos idées
le discours que de quelques que les
populations que les que les blés
médias tiennent que les peuples de les
réflexions des populations sont quand
même dans un espèce de cadres qui est le
cas de la démocratie ou c'est quand même
assez verrouillé mais si tout ça était
dans un effet dans des régimes qui ne
sont pas des régimes disons sajoo
démocratique ou ou avec des idées plutôt
pluraliste plutôt large etc
si c'était dans des régimes terrifiant
pas forcément ceux qu'on aime
alors là je comprendrais que cette
liberté d'action et d'avancer puisse
mener vers des choses terribles
nous sommes dans des cadres quand même
dans un cadre d'une société qui
fonctionne et qui a des règles très
élargie très large mais qui sont quand
même précisé on n'est pas quand même
dans le temps en 1939 dans la politique
menée pendant manille où il ya un
référendum petit peu interdits
absolument un mariage ne devrait pas
entre nos mines favret verrait là on est
dans le sens contraire qui fait partie
de l'europe quand même c'est ça aussi ça
pose des problèmes n'ayant pour ce que
ce qu'est l'europe et zurich en
alternance y autoriser en allemagne 39
commun avec un sens de la morale qui qui
explosent alors là ça devient très
dangereux
nous sommes quand même dans un cadre où
la morale existe elle continue d'être
respecté en fait toutes les opinions
sont présentes
il me semble que c'est un très bon cadre
qu'on est en partance pour tous voilà
vous avez sur d'autres raisons si c'est
que notamment la la la pma la gpa encore
plus pose en effet un certain nombre de
départs on peut tout à fait sur le rôle
de la femme dans une sorte de
marchandisation du corps c'est vrai
qu'il peut y avoir débat là dessus tout
à fait normal qu'on méprise la question
se pose tout à fait légitimement comme
absolument oui non et c'est bien qu'ils
aient des débats après qu'il décrit
spatiaux c'est un peu différent quoi oui
parce que les crispations à son général
elle met tout sur le même niveau
elle
elles sont sans nuance voilà et c'est ça
que je trouve un tout qui vivait dans
l'est dans les indications contre le
mariage pour tous il y avait pas tout le
monde mais une certaine partie
d'homophobie de se retrouver il existait
quand même non mais oui ça c'est
absolument évident non non ça je pense
que personne n'ira jusqu'à nier après
c'était aussi facile de réduire les
opposants au mariage pour tous à une
manifestation de mauvaise surprise hier
c'était raté qui les praticiens très bas
n'avait bien sûr ici ici sont très mal
pris d'un côté et les autres qui sont
très bien pris de l'autre pour appuyer
la cip rando le par mais il se révèle
moins facile pour ce pour l'épauler pour
les pros pour les pour donner s'ils sont
assez bien pris parce que ça crée aussi
un mouvement enfin important dire le
soutien par exemple de de fillon à la
présidentielle s'était s'était notamment
des participants à la manifestation
contre le risque pour tous ces écueils
avec le débat qui a lieu sur la ferment
et qui aura peut-être lieu sur la gpa
étant donné que le ministre et le
président ont vécu l'expérience du
mariage pour tous et donc du coup je
pense qu'ils vont essayer deux alors
c'est déjà la ministre de la santé qui a
dit qu'elle voulait désisté risée
un bac elle avait d'ailleurs il avait eu
des mauvais symbole pour les
manifestants option 1 contre nancy mais
disons qu'il avait des milliers etc qui
comprenait parfois leurs réactions quoi
c'est là qu'il faut donc écouter quand
même dans un débat qui ressemble un
petit point celui qu'on a eu il ya
quelques années le dessus peut-être
qu'on aura plus d'apaisement autour de
cette question ça serait bien si je
crois le débat autour d'yves et gêne ou
extrêmement violent extrêmement violent
et sa durée bien des années après elle à
la légalisation de 75 ans quoi ce
message mais dans le bilan après il ya
encore des débats terrible qu'il
entendait s'inspirer justement de là de
la manière dont simone veil s'est battu
à ce moment là parce que justement elle
a réussi à ne pas en faire un combat
féministe non plus n'y a crispé
finalement les volontés entre les pro et
les contrats et en essayant de démontrer
sa comme une forme d'évolution de la
société et je crois que c'est un peu le
le champ lexical qui essayent de
développer le ministre à l'heure
actuelle et il lui reste à trouver une
personnalité génial j'ai dit giscard
était de ton fils de siem si vous ne
faites qu'ils étaient bien istres de la
santé il faut dire que le canut et qui
était catholique émises de la justice
n'avait pas voulu défendre le projet de
loi allant trouver une personne était
aussi mirobolante de boulot pour makoun
remplaçant que l'on est trop
il faut il faut qu'on se dit dans
quelques secondes on amouyal salon de
l'auto vous y arriviez les postes avec
talent et les acheter non non non non
mais c'est tout y est beaucoup de choses
virtuelles beaucoup de voitures
économiques beaucoup et écologique ou de
voitures électriques non non c'est c'est
eh bien non c'est là aussi un site
il faut une voiture à sept places
électrique c'est juste un tout petit
point inquiétant il ya quand même un an
-2 d'exposants moins en moins de place
et c'est assez curieux est assez curieux
d'ailleurs moins de constructeurs
allemands de l'est stands se redresse
rétrécissent un peu choisir entre le
salon de l'auto et le salon jardin je
préfère sa nouvelle chantilly dans vie
joue aujourd'hui jour non messieurs le
grand festival de grande vadrouille ou
fait lit on peut le regarder grâce à ce
livre aux éditions ulmer de livres de
ses garçons et puis je rappelle le
journal de maurice garçon 39 45
pendant des années de guerre c'est chez
fayard c'est l'aubaine merci infiniment
merci à vous versiez c'est un garçon
assis jambes attitude claire bezina
charlène et booster la joie dit jean
charles et à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de poste
[Musique]